This is a pretty involved lesson. And I don't expect you to absorb it all at
once. But I do want you to at least heard of the idea. I know it's taken me
about 20 years to really grasp this whole concept. Let's get started. In
previous lessons we've seen that the order of transforms for an object is
usually rotate and then translate. For example, we start with the letter F, at
the origin. If we rotate it negative 45 degrees, we get a tilted F. We then
translate it by one unit vertically, and it moves up. This we write out as TR,
with the matrices applied in reverse order. However, we're now able to use
matrices which ever way we want. So say we reverse the order. If instead we
first translate up a unit, then rotate, we get this, the notation RT. Clearly
different, with T changing the origin we then rotate around. Here is another way
to look at it. Say we first just rotate the F. We express this by the notation
R. We could add a translation matrix before or after this rotation. If we add it
before the R this means we translate the object after the rotation and so move
it with respect to the world. Whatever happens before this translation was
applied is said and done. The object is in whatever orientation that has already
been set. Ancient history, so TR is this top case as before. If we put the T
after the R, it says to apply the translation first so everything is rotated
around the origin. So finally I haven't said anything new. However, another way
to look at all this is you're changing the frame of reference by each of these
transforms. Instead of rotating or translating the object, we can think about it
as changing this frame of reference. By taking this new path, we can think of
the transforms in these terms. First the rotation changes the frame of reference
that any transforms to the right of it will use. Then the translation moves the
object with respect to this new frame of reference. Any point of space is given
some x y z coordinate only with respect to something. We started off by thinking
of this something as world space, but notice that we have actually been making
things in what we call model space, and then transforming them to world space.
For example, when we have a parent child relationship, the child is oriented
with respect for the parent, not the world. So it's all about respect. Just a
little bit. When we put the T matrix after the R, we're saying to translate with
respect to the view of the world of the R matrix. So putting the T here, moves
the objects with the respect to the R matrices frame of reference. That is, the
translation is done with respect to the R's y axis. Putting the T in front of
the R means that the translation is not done in the R's frame of reference, but
in the world's frame of reference. The R itself is now influenced by the T's
frame of reference. Another way to say this is that the first matrix to the
right of some given set of matrices is transforming the object with respect to
that set. In other words, everything to the left of it. For example, on the top
here, the rotation is transforming the F with respect to the frame of reference
of the T translation to its left. This all may sound obtuse, but think of
someone looking at a hubcap in your model, he wants to know where it's located
and what angle it's at. You might describe it as well, I moved the hubcap so
it'd be properly attached to the wheel, and then I moved the wheel so that. But
he cuts you off, I don't care how it got there, where is it now. When you
position the hubcap you weren't really moving the hubcap to its position you are
positioning it with respect to wheel's frame of reference. And then you are
positioning the wheel with respect to the car's frame of reference. It's more
like the car's location and the wheel's location were maps for where the hubcap
should go. Different frames of reference are just like you might use latitude
and longitude to fly somewhere. Then use a street map, a different frame of
reference, to get from the airport to the office. Then use a map of the building
to find the room you want. Each frame of reference takes you to the next.